pour en parler nous sommes avec elio
eduardo rodriguez perdomo ambassadeur de
cuba en france bonsoir monsieur
l'ambassadeur merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rc france avant de parler de
ces essais cliniques et de cette
vaccination
quelle est la situation sur place à cuba
bon je me suis donné d'indication bon et
comme le char est bien impliqué le notre
reportage il ya une augmentation de la
circulation du virus dans les pennois de
cette année on avait réussi à bien
contrôler la situation des virus géants
dépassé par contre après la réouverture
des frontières à la fin de l'année le
mans il est des ruches à plus souple et
mais il faut dire que tout parent champ
par rapport à d'autres pays la situation
est assez bien contrôlé jusqu'à
maintenant aux populations de 11.2
millions d'habitants on a eu 100 g et k
début de la pandémie - des vies changent
et c'est malheureusement un peu moins de
vauchamps baissé mais comme vous devriez
est compact et ses données des mois
c'est là la situation des bureaux
chasser a été assez bien contrôlé et le
plus important que vous avez mardi a
mentionné elle est otage on a bien
avancé sur nos manières bat finale et
deux d'entre eux qui sont déjà en
pasquale d'études cliniques dont le
dernier un parti de pasqua et sam usher
dérivés commencer à vacciner une partie
de la population sans doute au val siné
cette année pendant cette année la
totalité la population plus belle des
manière volontaire évidemment cela me
permet que des ministères ont pleinement
notre population
on a l'art et 2001 effectivement à cuba
qui n'a pas attendu la fin de ces essais
cliniques et qui décide finalement
d'être pragmatique c'était la bonne
décision pour vous sans doute que non
non qualité des vaccins en pp tout le
ton contre les il y a eu il dément dont
les deux premières phases des dupes
initiale a parfois des centaines de
milliers de cubains qui ont d'été ont
participé dans ce super league
les résultats ont été contrôlés par nos
patients des médicaments on devait très
favorable et ça nous a permis d élargir
la dernière phase de déprime pour qu'un
père du champion de la population nous
espérons avoir mais pendant le mois de
mai des poubelles de charme ils vivent
déjà avec matinale le plus en danger et
on attend la autorisations finales et
d'autres payantes médicaments pouvoir
élargir la campagne de vaccination a
plus de la population et dont les
prochaines semaines alors comment réagit
justement cette population on a vu au
début de la vaccination en france les
français par exemple été extrêmement
sceptique quant au vaccin là il n'y a
pas eu d'essais cliniques venait
jusqu'au bout vous pensez que tout le
monde va courir pour se faire vacciner
ou il y aura quand même un petit peu de
défiance nous nous savons nous a
habitués à halle où la chine est au bout
connaissiez nous avons développé notre
industrie pharmaceutique et de
production des vaccins
mais plus que les 30 ans puis bas audi
j'ai déjà vécu 30 ans oui des rentes
vaccins qu'on utilise au niveau de notre
relation
c'est à dire les gens sont invités à
couper latine et jusqu'à maintenant il y
avait vraiment un intérêt important de
la population désespère la chine et les
plus tôt possible
alors nous on voit pas comment des
inconvénients de la volonté d'aider des
pays bas att va au contraire
hier le mans elle beaucoup de soutien à
développer des campagnes de vaccination
la plus touchée à quels autres vaccins
ressemble le vexin cuba on parle tout le
temps des balades et vexant dhainaut
virus astrazeneca johnson & johnson
arn moderne ait fader est le vôtre
cependant nous avons développé notre
charité quand il ya des lecteurs
si la méthode traditionnelle on n'oblige
pas la reine dans ta g on a à partir des
deux prochains de production des vaccins
et on a on a vraiment constaté dès que
le vent résultat un bon pour seule tâche
démonisation donc c'est pour cela qu'on
est vraiment mise c'est qu'on est
conscient qu' on est dans les meilleures
conditions pour arracher avec notre
campagne de vaccination ça va nous
situer dans une situation peu léger par
rapport aux autres pays deviendra le
leader or en la matière en amérique
latine si les autorités donnent le feu
vert à cette vaccination sans but et
sans doute on est précieux nist ça va
nous permettre d être un des premiers
pays du tiers monde à pouvoir amener
toute sa population et surtout avec ces
couacs le vaccin est un grand ciel pour
notre ans depuis son match épique pour
notre industrie nos marchands préférés
du temps justement le disait en cuba qui
deviendrait le leader pour la matière en
amérique latine vous seriez prêt du coup
à exporter autour de vous chez vos
voisins qui en ont bien besoin aussi
nous pensions que cette année on chez
alter pas super en tenant compte de
notre capacité industrielle de pouvoir
produire à peu près d'un million de
doses on estime à avoir échappé de peu
près 25 et 30 millions des doses ou par
la fim et toute la population tout
permettre dé pouvoir disposer des auges
des millions des doses additionnelles
pour partager avec itération à s'appuyer
on est ouverts avancer dans cette nation
moment merci beaucoup monsieur
l'ambassadeur idiot à dos les douars
d'eau rodriguez perdomo d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france pour nous
évoquer ce vaccin cubain